Hi, this is Taryn from Somerville, Massachusetts.
Radiolab is supported by dash digital cash,
the quick and easy way to send money to anyone in the world from anywhere in the
world.
Dash arrives within seconds and transactions are instant secure and optionally
private dash is digital cash. For more information,
visit dash.org/radio lab.
Hello, I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab or our topic today is what is our topic today?
Robert today is making life that isn't there before you arrived in the room.
Okay. A life not as we know it yet, but as we might invent it or make it.
Well let's talk about life. You and I. Okay.
So when you look around in the world that living things and I say, Look Dad,
there's a cat next to that is a dog and that's a tree.
And you noticed that those things of course are different. Yes.
And later when we go to school we learn about phylums and categories like
kingdoms and stuff.
So you think about the nature of those differences and then you're taught about
struggle and competition. Darwin species. Yes.
There is a new theory that's being talked about that turns all of that on its
head. I heard it first from this guy. I'm Steve Strogatz.
I'm an applied mathematician at Cornell and the story he told me,
which is based on analysis of DNA and very tiny organisms, microbes,
is that once upon a time he says, life began with a very primitive,
very simple collection of cells and these cells said,
[inaudible] these cells like to shoot. It appears that legend,
when you go back far enough, there is a kind of rampant sharing of molecules.
That's a kind of orgy in which there are no well-defined species or organisms
and I can give you my genes and you can pass. We're a calm unit.
It was a commune.
What does that mean? He's like, it was a commune. What do you mean?
What does it mean me? I know what it means in the 60s screen. Love sense,
but what does it really mean? What? Oh, what cells are exchanging is chemicals,
chemicals that give them talents and traits. Genes. Here's what happens.
I did this with [inaudible]
in that our, in our ancient puddle,
when Darwin thought the life might've begun in a warm puddle,
let's say that you and I are both cells. Okay?
So once upon a time there was you and the puddle and I'm in the same level as
you and it gets a little colder in the puddle. So we should all get sick,
but you don't get sick. You have some kind of accidental talent.
You can handle cold water. I'm shivering.
Describe again what happens in it at this point in the glorious old days. Well,
my membrane that is, I am a cell. I've got a membrane, I've got my outer layer,
maybe a little bit porous and maybe, whoops, I'm on my jeans just leaked out.
Okay,
we're not talking sophisticated organisms and maybe your poorest too and oh wow.
You just absorbed some of those genes. So now we both have this.
We both got you both.
And if I've got this gene now I can survive cold water cause it's pine to meet.
And if I bump into you now it's part of you.
So now the Steve Gene has become a Robert King,
which has then become a Jag gene and we're doing this over and over and over and
we're getting really, um, come here.
Sounds so friendly. No,
actually I don't think of sales like people shout out
all these exchanges. This gene swapping was not intentional.
It's not purposeful sharing. That's Nigel Goldenfeld.
I'm a theoretical physicist at the University of Illinois and he and his
colleague Carl woes did the science that led to some of these kind of goofy
ideas. It's not me sort of saying, hey,
I'm going to just help out my buddy over there.
Here's a couple of jeans and I think you'll find handy.
It's not something like that. You can still,
if we're swamping genes so much and you know,
you're giving me yours and I'm going to be nine. Yeah.
What does it actually mean to be me? Yeah.
So much of me is sped around. Well, it would be very weird.
Imagine a world in which for a while I have your nose, God forbid,
and then I get my nose back. You have Steve's hair.
Then I Steve would get my ear. Then he would get your nose on two stall,
having a lot of exchange. I'll take your chin. Okay. And you can have my,
um, allergies. And then you start even asking what does it mean, um,
to be a species. You can have my love affair with doubt.
You may not even be able to talk about individuals. Yeah.
If the mixing is good enough, we're all kind of indistinguishable.
So identity would be very strange in this ancient world.
All of the concepts that we take for granted,
biology become more and more nebulous as you get further and further back to the
roots of the origin of life. Take for instance, Charles Darwin.
What Nigel was really saying is that for the first billion years of life with
the being good to be everything that Darwin teaches,
all that stuff hasn't happened to no borders, no individuals.
There's no species. That is Darwinism evolution as we now understand it.
That's an interlude
[inaudible]
and the real story of life, it's only what's happening now.
What you got back at the very beginning was a whole bunch of cells swapping
genes, swapping advantages, swapping disadvantages,
and this kind of go wild time.
What tremendous explosion of diversity in a way that life has not seen since
then.
[inaudible]
until
one dark and terrible day 3 billion years ago as interpreted by Freeman Dyson,
sweetening famous physicist and delivered here. Now our friend,
the mathematician, Steve's drug as here is d one evil day,
a bacterium anticipating Bill Gates by 3 billion years,
refuse to share,
refuse to share who the first bad guy is.
This Cellular Bill K Two who decides that I've got an innovation that I don't
feel like sharing or possibly by found a way to keep my membrane from leaking.
That is, I'm not going to be a sharing soul anymore. And why?
I mean what made that one little cell decide to stop sharing?
That's a good question. We don't really know,
but what we do know this is was maybe the most dramatic moment in the history of
life on earth.
Uh Huh.
This transition from the age of, well,
if you want to call it the age of sharing to the age of selfishness.
And gradually once one creatures stopped sharing,
pretty soon the others followed. And then more and more did the same thing.
And now for the first time in the history of life, finally we get Darwin.
Now we get species. Now we see differences. Yes,
it's the age of identity of individualism. It's also the age of Stacy.
Things change, but they change much more slowly at any great thing. You know,
like you are a bat and you figured out sonar. I don't have sonar,
I can't get sonar. I mean I used to have sonar.
Like you're in a little electric fish that lives in the muddy waters of the
Amazon. You don't care. It's totally dark. You can see,
because you can see with electricity, I can't see with electricity.
If I'm in the dark, I'm bumping my head.
[inaudible]
okay, so here's go.
We end up chapter one one a green orgy of gene swapping. Chapter two,
your g as we pass genes. Now, not to other guys,
not randomly but just to our own children. And finally here comes
chip that's proposed by Freeman Dyson, the physicist Freeman Dyson.
After 3 billion years of life,
slowly evolving through random mutations who bumps in the night,
one species, Jad human beings, you and me,
we have become so smart,
so well some of us so technologically advanced that we can swap genes.
We now decide who gets what genes and thanks to us evolution as Darwin described
it is beginning to end and now we welcome evolution as described by Freeman
Dyson to the graduating class University of Michigan.
I see a bright future for the biotech industry becoming small and domesticated
rather than big and centralized.
Freeman thinks that in the future everybody means everybody.
They will all be creating new life forms and why? Because they can.
That will be do it yourself.
Kits for gardeners who will use genetic engineering to breed new varieties of
roses and dog kids kips for lovers of pigeons and parrots and lizards and snakes
to breed new varieties of pets, genetic engineering.
Once it gets into the hands of housewives and children will give us an explosion
of diversity of new living creatures.
[inaudible]
the final step in the domestication of biotechnology will be biotech games
designed like computer games for children down to kindergarten age,
but played with real eggs and seeds.
Rather than with images on the screen playing such games,
kids will acquire an intimate feeling for the organisms that they're growing.
The winner could be the kid who seed grows,
the picklist cactus or the kid whose egg hatches the cutest dinosaur.
[inaudible]
so there's your future. I'd like to make it your future for the moment, right.
My little foot doesn't sound that bad. I mean, maybe a little Saifai well,
actually,
here's the interesting thing is that what he's describing has already begun.
There are kids doing this right now or something very close to it.
How old were you when you did this? I guess I was 20 and 21 right now.
Okay. Who are you, what's your name and what do you do? Uh, I'm Steven Payne.
I'm a senior in biological engineering at MIT. Oh,
here's the thing about Steven.
He like most kids who are in the sciences in college had to spend hours and
hours and hours in the lab waiting for eco lie slowly grow in a petri dish.
Eco Line, like the stuff that gives you food poisoning. Well, yeah, it's,
it's the stuff that you, it's common bacteria that lives naturally in your gut.
And it's, by the way, a big laboratory favorite.
And the problem is as freshman Seth, he was a Grad student at MIT.
Is he calling in the Ra?
Actually, I smelled really bad. What does it smell like?
I actually kind of smell, I guess maybe like now
what do you think? It smells like
feces. Anyway,
Steven and his friends got into their heads that they could make Nike Colada
smell nicer, nicer,
suddenly like cinnamon or cherry or like minty fresh.
We ended up deciding on Wintergreen, wintergreen. Oh,
you got something against wintergreen. Let me know.
In the real world who has winter green? Ah, it's the Petunia plant.
Petunias have wintergreen. I have no idea.
Yeah. A lot of folks study why plants make nice smells.
So why do roses smell nice? Why do Petunia Smell Nice?
So what we did was we requested from one of these folks and Natalia Duda River
from Purdue university.
We asked her to send us a sample of one of the genes she had studied that
produces this winter green smell. She mailed it through the mail.
We opened it up, they took it.
What were you taking out? A little bit of gunk. It's actually living cells.
Living dried cells. Yeah.
We pulled out the DNA, put it into a new cell
and once the new DNA had done its thing, Steven called everybody into the lab
and we all came over and were like, Whoa, these,
you know the Ceco like culture actually does smell like mint.
And we were like, Yay. That's crazy. Yeah.
So instead of smelling pool all day, they get to smell a wintergreen. Well,
actually there was more than that because after their winter green success,
Steven and Rashman decided, you know, why should we stay in the,
in the lab all day,
even though it smells nicer now because we have to sit there and watch these
equal, I grow and grow and grow until they are ready to be experimented on.
We could be outside playing Frisbee.
So they decided to put a little trigger inside the Ecoli.
So when it's done growing,
it switches from winter green to banana, banana,
banana. So banana.
It smells like a banana milkshake.
I mean it smells more like a banana than a banana does.
Okay, so winter green means it's still growing and banana means we're done. Yup.
Wow. That's kind of awesome. [inaudible] awesome is a word I want to discuss.
The awesome question here. Okay.
Were you at all intrigued by the idea that, as far as I know,
and I'm maybe as far as you know,
maybe as far as anybody know in the history of the eco-line creature,
there has never been an eco lie that smelled like winter green.
Yup. You made it yourself.
Well, we need to help them. My team members. Yes.
Did you feel a little spooked by the fact that you just created a life form new
to new to creation? Um,
I mean at least we're doing something that's, you know,
smells pleasant but you didn't feel like a doctor.
Frankenstein or a god or a not at all. What do you,
what does it feel like to make something that's never existed before?
This feels like basic engine.
Yeah. Or engineers. I would say we're engineers. We're building stuff,
building stuff. Stop building
stuff on living stuff.
So
[inaudible] stand clean cause your away and Jen
will fix the problems of today by building stuff with the licensing genes where
the building creatures being extra useful features.
No more wasting daughter Winston slopping jeans as is small.
So building stuff
[inaudible] goes whereby Yo [inaudible] slobbing gene.
Yes man kinds. Only fighting chance designer genes. Not Denny Bites.
We'll stop disease and greenhouse gases eat when seeing nucleic acids crack the
code. We've seen the light where the
road is bright and clear.
[inaudible]
building stuff.
Thanks to Josh [inaudible] and Shane Winter for that music radio lab.
We'll continue in a moment.